so welcome to the planning and
Regulatory committee meeting
a welcome to committee members other
councilors and staff and anyone else who
may be tuning in at this time a special
welcome to for council's new policy
planner Morgan Edwards who's sitting
over here
who no doubt we will merge our paths and
and see from them a bit more as we move
forward
by way of introduction I just want to
make a few comments before getting in to
the formal agenda this is the first
meeting of the policy and planning
committee in several years and in part
it reflects the commitment made by
elected representatives provide for more
open government across all facets of
council activities and an opportunity
for counselors to pose questions and get
information on the matters that will be
dealt with rather than by way of
newsletters
to set the scene as it were the policy
and planning committee has
responsibility for a broad range of
regulatory functions of the council
these include food health and gambling
dogs and other animals glitter noise
alcohol licensing building control
consideration of all the bylaws of the
council some of which will also be dealt
with by order from risk committee and as
you'll see from the agenda there are two
bylaws that are currently due for review
roading and the dog control bylaw this
committee also ministers matters arising
from the implementation of the district
plan such as the overview of resource
consent and enforcement action the
committee also has an overview role of
the review of The District plan this
will focus on the process and progress
of the district plan review it's the
role of the district plan subcommittee
to consider the minute I of the detailed
provisions of the district pan plan and
to report progress to this committee and
once ready for notification to seek the
approval of this committee to recommend
to the council that notification take
place
with regard to policy that relates to
consideration of all of council's
policies some existing such as Financial
contributions and road stopping and
there is a report in the agenda
regarding this there will also be
however other new policies that we may
need to consider such as climate change
and adaptation and possibly something
like a waste minimization strategy
cutting across all of this the committee
is also charged with consideration of
issues associated with growth planning
and economic development
these tasks in total are immense and we
need to be efficient in the way we carry
out our tasks in that regard we'll need
to rely significantly on the council
staff and consultants and avoid
duplication of matters considered by
other committees because there is a
degree of potential or potential overlap
in that regard most importantly as a
committee in the council we need to
ensure that our outputs are efficient
and effective to implement without
unnecessarily booting our rate payers
with additional costs
there is one additional matter that I
wish to add to the agenda it is a minor
matter and I wish to do so under section
46a7a1 of the local government official
information meetings act to consider at
this meeting and that's the committee
title after considering the functions of
the committee I thought the current
title is misleading referring to policy
and planning after raising up with staff
I was advised it should be raised at
this meeting and it wasn't a matter of
the scar the staff considered they
needed to report on I don't believe it
can wait a further meeting and we should
agree to use the title from day one so
do I have a secondary to enable
consideration with the title of the
committee as part of this agenda
Stuart thank you
any discussion on that
consider it as part of it there is none
all those in favor say aye against
carried
turning to the formal agenda are there
any apologies and their apologies from
Bronwyn Reed and also from
and that's all just from Bronwyn
do I have a motion to accept the apology
of the absence of brom1 Council of
Richard
um mcphail and also Stuart McDonald
Declaration of Interest are there any
Declarations of interest for this
meeting
appear to be none
we'll deal first with the minor matter
the title of the committee are there any
thoughts regarding the name policy and
planning versus policy and Regulatory
none do we have uh someone prepared to
move a motion that this committee or we
request Council to refer to this
committee as policy and Regulatory
thank you Stuart seconded by glennis any
discussion none carried
the regulatory Services bulletin that
was a item prepared by Francis Shepard
who was not present I don't think no
um are there any matters arising from
that Bulletin
none do I have a mover for the motion
that the report be accepted
Richard seconded by Stewart
any discussion none all those in favor
say aye against carried
building control activities Russell
Patterson writer of the report is
present Russell welcome is there
anything additional you want to add or
update since the report was written
have you got a mic there with you
sorry the February stats are now
available which aren't part of this
report they're available since this was
written and they continue on the same
sort of trend of
87 to 90 percent consents issued under
20 days which is pretty consistent we're
not reaching 100 but during the current
sort of atmosphere we're striving to get
there
other than that
um projects coming up I talked there
about the various things coming up and
referred to a meeting with the hwr my
Transport Group which we had last week
and as chief executive attended and
along with quite a few staff and it was
quite informative
so um about their um their activities
are planning for not only the
hydrogen plant but also for the
relocation of the truck wash to down the
end of Faulkner Road
so yeah do councilors have any questions
of Russell
councilor McKenzie
Russell excuse my ignorance the hydrogen
thing is this for like fuel cells or
hydrogen it stores as a gas
it's because the fuel cell I understand
is a
thing that's run on hydrogen that
creates electricity
is it that line or or is it keeping the
hydrogen as a gas to run engines off
drip
they are they're proposing they've got a
building consent which is on my desk at
the moment and it's nearly through the
process to
um install and manufacture and storage
facility for for 10 of their own Fleet
that they're going to convert to
hydrogen they're going to have a fleet
of 10 trucks that are going to be dual
fuel so they're directly inject hydrogen
into the air intakes of the motors and
they told us if I can remember correctly
it should
reflect on about a 40 percent
saving of fuel so effectively the trucks
can run on diesel and hydrogen mix so
they're they're um longevity or the or
their root can be extended before
they've got a refuel I think this is
quite an exciting thing to be happening
in yeah as the first in New Zealand I
believe to be manufacture and Storage
any other questions
Richard
yeah just through the chair to Russell
as soon as we've got you here and answer
the question staff training obviously um
fantastic you've got a day Mark there
that is well I'm sure they should be
noted uh
just in regard to the administration of
consents I'm just really an update for
myself or maybe the other counselors the
process we changed the computer process
or the administrative process a couple
of years ago I think it was
that all settled like is it all process
wise or is it still quite
um
an effort or
um how is that transition with time
that's probably the question I'm asking
sure okay now good question
um it has settled I think it's a matter
of the staff becoming used to the
process as well and the customers to a
fair degree
most customers now are pretty
um pretty clued up when they're lodging
a online application we still do have
some turn up at the counter with a fist
of hard copy paper they're trying to
shuffle into some sort of format
but generally they're all online format
we do we have a streamlining process
we're about to embark on and to try and
streamline our process because it's
still quite
inclusive if that's the right word
and I wouldn't say that it's faster than
a hard copy processing of consents but
it's certainly far more thorough so we
just got to draw the line between
assessing the risk of cutting out some
of that
thoroughness if you like to you know on
a risk-based sort of process
Russell I note that in in your report
these details of the consents issued the
location and the value
is that the only information that's made
public as part of building consent or
can someone come along and have a look
at someone else's consent
through through the chair I'm actually
you can do a property search
and obviously you can find anything
that's on the public record
once a consent is issued it becomes a
public record on as a TA record
but anything once the building where it
begins and any of the field inspection
reports or anything like that don't
become a public record until
code of compliance is issued so they're
not officially in the TA records
yeah
all right any other comments from
counselors cleanness
is there a Slowdown in building because
of the cost escalations have you found
that or
we've noticed a slight decline yeah to
be fair
um I was at a a southern Cluster meeting
in Dunedin on Friday and it's it's
certainly noticed further up the country
Timaru and waitaki are both noticed to
quite a drop-off and residential work
we've noticed a slight drop off
um
but on the flip side of that we're
probably getting quite a bit of interest
in commercial activity it's still it's
still surging on
um
so yeah it is starting to to drop off I
would say yep
all right can I have a mover and a
second uh sorry
um
oh
thank you sorry just while we're on the
topic of hydrogen and I do apologize I
meant to catch up with you about that
hydrogen project do you think from the
discussion that you had it's worth
educating elected members on that
project or getting them to educate
elected members I just recognize that
the first Port of Call when they see
construction or here rumors is going to
be to come to councilors I just would
hope that the team's informed just based
on what use or do you think do you think
it would be necessary or is it more of a
nice to have
um I don't know whether it's totally
necessary I mean the presentation that
we're presented with by the my transport
team was very informative
um that gave us some good visuals and a
lot of good narrative to go with it
um going into the into that meeting I
was quite skeptical and thinking this is
this is quite a dangerous sort of a
sight potentially but
um they certainly assured us that it's
nowhere near as dangerous as a petroleum
site
and obviously if any hydrogen does
escape it goes straight up at high
pressure
so there's no gases on the ground
um so effectively anything that does get
out of there is going to go straight
into the atmosphere so there's no real
risk to
the general public or users from what we
understood that we fear Steve
yep yep
in some respects I guess it's a bit like
when LPG came along there were all these
concerns expressed and there were
explosions and Mexico and an
invercargill one of the gangs opposed an
LPG plant on the site next door to them
because they're concerned that a rival
game would blow it up and affect them as
well so there's just the change in
degree of uncertainty so can I have a
move on a second there for the motion
that will report be received please
cleanness and Steward all those in favor
say aye against carried right we turn to
page 18 the roading bylaw review Murray
hesler the writer is present welcome
Murray we have read dual reporters there
anything additional you would like to
add please
it's true Mr chair uh thank you
um yeah I just want to highlight that
that we do have several issues that have
been highlighted in looking at the
existing writing bylaw that that
definitely do need to be updated one of
those being speed limits as you'll note
in my report the the methodology and
apparatus for setting speed limits is
has become a a
centralized process so that's that's
something that will need to be repealed
or rescinded by Council
when we um when we bring the
um the reviewed
um by law before the committee
um
there's also a number of traffic issues
that have developed since the
um so it's the the current
um
bylaw was put in place and we discussed
some of those issues at the material
community board meeting last night
and what one of those is the problem
that these are listed in the um in my
report but I just really wanted to
highlight highlight them a Prohibition
of overnight parking of heavy commercial
vehicles and urban residential streets
this this is becoming is proliferating
in both Matera and Gore and it has been
the subject every now and again from
from the public of complaints
um
it also causes damage to our roads a lot
of our residential streets are exactly
that the residential streets are not
built to have loaded logging tracks
packed up overnight outside a
residential
um
premises
another issue
is is possibly
um the
um prohibition of heavy commercial
vehicles from certain parts of a network
unless they do have legitimate business
um it is something that uh is covered uh
by a number of other townships
um around around the around the South
I'm particularly thinking of crime all
large parts of Cromwell and other some
other townships in central otago have
probation of um heavy vehicles
that possibly may be using certain
um
certain Urban streets as as shortcuts
rather than using the the roads that are
being designated and constructed for
those for that traffic
um we've also
do have an issue in matara with the
Costa Park area which is where the old
key stores
did sit and was demolished several years
ago but it has by defecto has become a
truck parking area
um
and um
a Prohibition of park at trucks parking
there is is something that the community
board
um was quite keen on
the other the other issue another also
another issue that has come to our
attention and was mentioned on on our
council at all was an issue with
um encroachment of permanent fencing in
some of the rural areas uh on and within
the road Reserve we do we do have
several appendices in the existing
roading by law that cover this issue and
it is an issue that I will be bringing a
report to the committee in the near
future regarding
um potential action to be taken in this
situation I was just looking at the
appendices that um or the issues that
are actually affected and there was five
five of the appendices in the um uh that
that potentially have uh breaches of of
our requirements um in that situation so
uh we'll we're doing further
investigation into that and as I say we
will be bringing a report
um on that particular subject uh
I suspect the the the one that was the
property that was mentioned or the the
area that was mentioned on the Council
of tour is unlikely to be the only
um example of uh similar some of the
behavior I suppose um that that we do
need to deal with as it is public
property uh boundary to boundary uh in
the right corridor
um yeah so that that's um
that's
uh the highlights that I I'd like to
bring to you thank you Murray are there
any questions of Murray or it is an
opportunity of any issues that
councilors may be aware of that you
would like to see addressed in the bylaw
um glennis
thank you Mr chair
um I'm just wondering Murray
um we if we don't provide an area for
trucks to park where would you expect
them to be parking I mean we don't want
to say you're not allowed in town or you
so there's a lot of we do have a lot of
truck drivers that live in Gore so where
would we be expecting them to park
uh through Mr chair um what what happens
in other districts is that
um generally it's the residential zoned
streets that are subject to the
prohibition
and there's quite a number of streets uh
particularly in Gore that our industrial
or commercial that are already being
used for parking Gorton Street's a good
example of that
splitting Hyde Park
and there are a number of other similar
streets but it really is
it's an issue that the the actual
trucking companies should be dealing
with rather than the public having to
provide those facilities because as
quite a bit of
cost involved in
providing those sorts of facilities
um
the the other thing that uh happens in
in some other places
um some quite close to us is that
um trucking companies that don't have a
have a base or a yard in a particular
town make an arrangement with another
company to allow the attracts to park
over overnight but what we have noted is
that particularly in the Matera issue at
Costa Park is that the trucks that are
parking there are actually
um local drivers they're not they're not
um drivers from out of town breaking
their journey
and
they've started parking in Costa park
because it's it's handy and and talking
to the
um the road transport station or what's
now named the transporting New Zealand
the company the sorry the organization
that represents all of the uh most of
the trucking companies what their
comment was is that it's it's basically
laziness on part of the truck drivers in
a lot of cases
um wanting to park outside their house
overnight rather than parking the the
track and a yard because some of these
trucks May well ever have a base or a
yard in in um in the township um
so we we want to get rid of those trucks
from the residential areas they do cause
quite a bit of damage particularly if
they
um are parking regularly and sometimes
they can be loaded and there's quite a
bit of extra weight there that that does
um damage the pavement so there is a a
real cost as well as annoyance and
inconvenience to the public
any other comments or feedback
Murray one one that's been drawn to my
attention and and it's continued for
some time is the habit of a number of
heavy vehicles from adjoining Council
areas to be using our gravel rural roads
as a shortcut to State highways and I
hope to see something in the bylaw
relating to that
if you've got any comment
uh yes some thanks for bringing that up
um that that is a good example of the
types of issues that aren't uh currently
covered in our writing bylaw that
um that councilors uh should take the
opportunity if they are aware of those
sorts of problems to to bring to us so
that we can investigate those issues and
a number of other
um councils do have
um do have uh parts of the Ebola that
that do preclude the use of those
um
uh an appropriate gravel roads for as
shortcuts Southland District's a good
example of that they have several that
I'm aware of that unless the trucks
actually have business legitimate
business on those roads then they can't
use those roads
um
so that's definitely a
um an issue that we would like to
address in in the review thank you can I
have a mover and a second for the
recommendation report be noted in the
committee note the proposed commencement
of the review of the road in bylaw
Richard and Stewart thank you
moving on to item next which is on page
20 which is the planning Services report
and we have a report from Katrina Ellis
senior planner of the property group
welcome Katrina thank you
um is is there anything that you want to
add or any updates since the report was
written uh just to note that when this
report was written was early in the year
so it just provides information to the
end of last year so at the next meeting
I'll do an update with the year to date
but essentially I'm still meeting time
frames 100 of the time consent numbers
are down a little bit that's quite
typical in January and February so we
don't yet know if it's a bit of a
downward Trend or just a quiet start to
the year
any comments or questions of Katrina
please
Katrina
the report includes details of consents
issued in the location and I guess
similar to the question that I put to
building control manager
it's my understanding that once accepted
for processing resource consent to
public information yes and so what
information on consensus released to the
public
on request
no and and termed well available to the
public yeah so uh
the consent folder essentially is
publicly available if somebody requests
to find out that information okay so in
the spirit of open government is there
any impediment supporting consents once
accepted for processing end decisions on
council's web page site no so do we need
a motion to ask for that to be done or
it will just
sorry we can take a note of that yes
okay thank you all right the
recommendation in that report says he um
so can I have a move on a second uh the
report be received please clearness
and
Stuart thank you
next item is the bylaw policy review on
page 22 a report from the chief
executive we've read the reports Steve
is there anything additional that you
want to add since it was written
I think it's just a report that lets the
committee know what lies ahead in terms
of uh by law and policy reviews and has
been committed to on the report now we
have Morgan Edwards on board we will be
reviewing at least two policies per
meeting uh but obviously the bylaws will
take a bit more time
in those first two that mentioned and
you've already had a a very
comprehensive introduction by Murray
Hasler about voting in dog control
there's a few issues we've got but in
the mainly I'm our feeling is that the
current by law is
um pretty pretty still fits the purpose
but there will be a few amendments
any questions or comments of Steve
please
the worship
um three years cheer would we be able to
get the same list of suggested policies
for the audition risk committee to
review as well um because I understand
that this list obviously we're exclude
any of those but the financial flavor
but a similar list for auditing risks
that they can chew through their
policies as well thank you
the list of policies are the set
paragraph 3.3
and they include ones dating back a
number of years
and I'm just wondering with regard to
the election signs policy it was
introduced in 2020 and was primarily
intended as a stop gap for the local
body elections that we've had
um we don't have new elections for
another
three years at the local level national
elections are later this year but the
legislation applies to them so I'm just
wondering to avoid any confusion where
there may be Merit and actually
um putting into a balance that policy in
the meantime
particularly this year to avoid any
confusion and also means it doesn't need
to be looked at for a couple of years
yet
been can I suggest to build on top of
that that
um win if this is to come back to the
committee that there is a bit of a a
schedule for priorities of which ones
you're going to tackle and when so that
we know as a committee which ones we're
we're going to be tickling and when um
of Interest
would you like to express that as a
motion please
sure can I'd like to put the motion that
uh
uh the suggested policies and and
furthermore all policies
um are added to a prioritized
effectively and then uh dates lined up
with uh the following committees as to
when those will be done so it's a big
motion but
just a priorities list for all policies
do we have a second difference
cleanness any discussion
is it worth adding to your
recommendation that the uh does anyone
have any objection to the election signs
policy been put into a balance being
added to that motion
uh through UTI I think I think when you
rank them by priority that one will
probably rank pretty low based on your
argument here today I don't know if
there needs to be added the
recommendation I would imagine there's
someone there that probably fall into a
similar category of where you can deal
with them when they're necessary they'll
be higher priority levels I would
imagine in that list
I'm going to open up a bit of a can of
worms here
um just a comment not a recommendation
it's just a comment that I believe
anybody that has an animal in the town a
dog they should be the ones that are
being licensed as fit owners of said
dogs
I just want to add that comment thank
you
not working dogs but get the gift of
what I mean
it's fit to own what's in the
legislation
through Mr chairman no the legislation
provides that the dog must be registered
and Leona has legislated
responsibilities
but anyone can
a list they are actually prohibited
through past misdemeanors can own a dog
there is however
a one province in Germany that I know
that actually has introduced a dog
licensing system where people have to
exhibit certain behaviors
with their dog to get a license to own
but some would say that's a very
authoritarian approach but uh there's no
currently under New Zealand legislation
if you want to own a dog you can do so
but the dog controller it does provide
certain obligations which attract
reasonable fines if you don't observe
those obligations
thank you any other discussion
appears to be clear
sorry there's just one thing that's not
on the agenda that with your permission
I'd like to raise
it's very quick question to Murray
if it relates to what was in his report
we've already dealt with it and we can
come back to eroding
it's about Streets Alive and a lot of
their streets and live infrastructure is
still on the roads and quite a number of
the the public are commenting about it
and would like it cleaned up
well I think that's that's a matter that
is being noted and um it should really
it will deal with it in another way
rather than as part of this in the
meantime but you do raise a valid point
that I've noted that of whispered in
this year
um so we have a have a motion that the
report be received and in general terms
that a list of priorities for review of
bar of the policies be presented to the
committee and and that's a similar list
is provided to audit and risk as well
yes
um so uh that was moved by you seconded
by cleanness all those in favor say aye
against carried that brings us to the
end of the agenda the meeting is closed
thank you councilors